- Usually I do
the introductions, but I—
This is you.
This is your guy.
- This is my guy.
I mean, this is
the original CJ2K.
My man right here.
I didn't know what to expect
when I saw
this guy in person as a player.
Like—
- Cuz he was a rookie
when you were there.
- He was a rookie.
And in training camp, I was
with the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
So I—
that team, as he'll tell you
had a bunch of Texas guys
on the Tennessee Titans team.
And they kept telling me,
"Man, this Chris Johnson
is a baller, man.
We've never seen
anybody so fast."
And I was like,
"Yeah, bleh, bleh, bleh, bleh."
But then I got there and
yes, one of the most special
talents I have ever been around.
- And then, your memories
of Chris Simms back then?
- Oh, man. He used to talk trash
to me before every game.
- Stop.
- I think it was probably
like Week 2 or Week 3.
He was like, "Ah, come on"
I was—I think I had went
for 100 yards, like, twice.
He's like, "Come on, man.
I'm tired of seeing these 10-,
15-yard runs.
Break off somethin' long."
I think, that same game,
LenDale broke for 80
and I came right back
and broke for, like, 76.
- Kansas City.
- Kansas City game.
He did.
- I feel like that's when the
Smash and Dash thing took off.
- Right. It did.
- When those two big
runs happened.
- Yeah.
- Yep.
- I think that's
a nickname that I feel like
they try to give
to a lot of duos now.
But you guys
were Smash and Dash.
- Yeah, yeah, we started that.
They asked us, like,
what was our name.
-Yes.
- And LenDale was like,
"We Smash and Dash."
- Right.
- He came up with Smash and Dash
and then ever since then
they just started
calling us that every week.
- Smash and Dash, OK
him and LenDale,
I mean, characters
and LenDale
especially a character.
- That's an all-time
running back room.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
And LenDale—
we can put him on blast now
cuz his career is over—
- [Laughing]
- He was late a lot, OK?
I mean, late a lot.
- Right.
- Like, and always had
a different excuse.
Creative as hell, right?
- How much is "late"?
- Yeah, see? He knows it's true.
Like, if we had an 8:30 meeting
LenDale was, I felt like,
never there at 8:30.
Never.
- And this is every day?
- I mean, at least once
or twice a week.
- OK.
- And he'd always have
some great excuse.
I mean, great.
What do you think
his best excuse was?
What was one you remember,
you remember any good ones?
- Yeah. He was late one time,
and he came in and he was like
"Man, I had to pull over
to the gas station bathroom
and my stomach was hurting.
I had to use the bathroom."
- He was just—
So his excuse was "I took a crap
at a gas station."
- I had to take a crap
in a bathroom, yes.
- And then when he says that,
the team explodes?
- No, actually.
Cuz it's a serious setting.
- [Laughing]
- I mean, we're all shaking
our head like
"What a bunch of bullcrap
that is."
But there's nothin' we can say
cuz Jeff Fisher is still
the head coach
and he's standing
in front of the room
and we're not gonna butt
into that conversation.
So I want to ask Mr. 4.24
who's the fastest guy
in the NFL right now?
- Tyreek Hill.
- OK.
- Gotta go with Tyreek Hill.
- Is it unreal how fast he is?
- He's fast.
- I mean, like, I'm not tryin'
to disrespect you
or Joey Galloway
or Deion Sanders
but he is the fastest f--ker
I have ever seen.
- Maybe he's the second-
or the third-fastest.
I wouldn't say the fastest.
- You wouldn't say
he's the fastest?
- Not the fastest.
- I know, cuz you're gonna
take yourself.
- Of course.
- I know.
- You should.
- What was bigger,
the 2,000 or the 4.24?
- 2,000.
- Mm.
But the 4.24 we had
never seen before.
You got the watch made,
all that.
- Yeah.
- When you saw John Ross
beat the 4.24—
- Eye emoji.
That was what he sent out, as
soon as he ran the—remember?
The official time hadn't came in
and he tweeted "eye emoji,"
the big eyes.
- Was there part of you
that was like
"I hope that gets corrected
and it's actually a 4.25."
- Probably a part of me.
But still to this day,
I don't believe he beat it.
- You still don't think
he ran a 4.22?
- No.
When you look—
OK, for one, when you look
at the side-by-side
I pulled off on him
at the end.
- Right.
- That's fascinating.
- And number two is,
when has it ever took
that long for the official time
to come in?
- It did take a long time.
You're right.
- Wow.
- So you believe
that it was rigged?
Just say it.
Say it with your chest.
- They probably got tired of,
tired of—
- Showing your highlight
all the time?
- Yeah, they probably got tired
of no one beating it
and felt like the combine
was getting boring, so—
- Right.
- They needed more attention.
- Needed more attention.
- I love it.
- I'm a big
conspiracy theory guy.
This is one of the best ones
I've ever heard.
- I'm telling you.
I don't believe it.
- I have to imagine you would go
out and people would be, like
in the club goin', "I'll race
you in the parking lot."
- Yeah.
- All the time?
- All the time.
- That's just the dumbest crap ever.
- Anywhere. Everywhere.
- The dumbest crap ever.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, they don't know
what they're messin' with.
- Since you are the master
of 40 times
we have some very famous
running clips from movies
that we'd like you to watch
and tell us what you think
their "40 times" would be.
- OK.
♪♪♪
- We're gonna start off first
this is the scene
from "Get Out."
So watch my man run.
We all remember the scene.
Scares the crap out of this guy.
Running straight at him.
Turns to the left side.
- Aw, man.
- That form is phenomenal.
His elbows are in perfect spots.
[Whooshing]
- That was 4.1 right there.
- A 4.1?!
- That was a 4.1.
Look how fast he's runnin'!
- So, you're admitting that
someone may be faster than you.
- Yeah, probably him.
- Wow.
- All right, next one is
"Mission: Impossible."
It is the crazy lunatic
that is Tom Cruise.
What do you think
Tom Cruise's 40 time was
in "Mission: Impossible"?
- Yeah, that's 4.3 right there.
- 4.3?
- Yeah, that's 4.3.
- You're being generous.
He's got the d—
- The duck feet. A little bit.
Yes, right. Yeah.
I mean, he's like 4.8ish to me.
No way he's beatin' me
in a race.
- Yeah, but he's going over stairs
and everything.
He's not even slowin' down.
- Yeah, he is.
All right. Next one up.
Much better movie.
"Bad Boys."
The king that is Will Smith.
Runnin' with the gun in hand.
And then he's gotta save
Martin Lawrence.
What do you think the top
speed that Will hit there was?
- He 4.8 right there.
That's 4.8.
- Oh!
- That's 4.8.
- Real low on Will Smith.
Now to a legendary runner.
The Forrest Gump.
In the khakis.
What do you think
his top speed there was?
- He looks 4.2 right there.
- 4.2?
- At the top speed right there.
- Right there?
- Yeah, right there.
- And then the last one
is Michael Cera in "Superbad."
As he's gonna run
from the cops here—
- Ah, man. He's a 5.5.
- Ohh, you see the knees buckle
and the legs out to the side?
- Yeah. Chris,
you're faster than him.
- I know.
I definitely am.
Thank you.
- All right, so let's recap these.
You have "Get Out"
as your leader at 4.1.
Coming in second place,
"Forrest Gump" at 4.2.
Third place,
"Mission: Impossible."
Tom Cruise at 4.3.
Will Smith shockingly gets
fourth place at a 4.8.
And Michael Cera,
appropriately, 5.5.
Do you agree
with his rankings there?
- I do. I thought maybe he was a
hair nice to Tom Cruise, but—
- I agree.
- But other than that,
it's pretty good.
- "Get Out" beats "Forrest Gump."
- Yep.
- Try to avoid going
to the sunken place.
Well, good luck to you,
my friend.
- Thank you.
- It was a pleasure
talking to you.
- Thank you.
- Way to go. You did it.